chaque chroniqueur va rentrer en
christophe hondelatte et aura une
révélation ou un reproche à faire sur
l'accusé de son choix
autour de la table donc le chroniqueur
de son choix j'appelle tout de suite le
premier hondelatte c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne peux pas papa
[Applaudissements]
lui c'est maxime gagné il serait il ne
serait pas l'auteur de tous ses scoops
maxime koenig je vous le demande est-il
un usurpateur
excusez moi c'est ça le sénat
et est-ce qu'on peut regarder apprendre
rocade et bien il faut que vous soyez
bien sûr cette caméra après cette caméra
fixe fléchir et merci je vais faire la
réal merci mon chéri et vous êtes
vraiment vraiment là-dessus mais
mettez-vous droit mais tu vous remercie
mes chéris merci merci et c'était une
catastrophe
pas grave c'est ça la révélation mais le
blond vous va très bien quand tu penses
merci en fait vous mettez des perruques
tous les jours en ce moment regarde on
est tellement démons magnum se passer la
période
en fait chacun 4 perruque d'eau qui
donne sur la pace diab renchéri allez
c'est parti à tokyo c'est parti le
procès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lui c'est benjamin castaldi
l'escroc de ses huit alias l'animateur
discount tout ce qu'il touche
ça ne marche pas aux achats landes les
présentations ne touche pas à mon poste
big le quiz alors jusqu'à quand larnack
va-t-elle durer
mais arrête ça gêne pas même pas
n'importe quoi à les recycler coppola
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
lui c'est jean michel maire
la dernière fois qu'il a bossé c'était
en 89 depuis pas une émission de télé il
a vu pas un film il n'avait pas une info
il a donné là moi j'appelle ça vous et
comment un emploi fictif
quel con vous appelez ça un emploi
fictif en vain de vue qui cartonne et
qu'on aime merci montmédy d'amour
magnifique auprès des très beaux
attention elle est répartie est
procédure elle a alors lu je me sens pas
du tout maxime gaming c'est gilles
verdez l'homme de tous les excès coheris
eric folie décapante
il devrait apprendre à fermer sa gueule
que ce qu'elle suive derrière sa
personnalité et il exprès la question
reste entière
bravo c'est le meilleur pour l'instant
c'est le meilleur pour l'instant merci
bravo
d'où les là je viens à vous merci à la
fais partie merci attention prochain ah
oui au lac à nivèse quelle tristesse
[Musique]
c'est isabelle morini bosc
ça fait plus de quatre ans qu'elle est
dans touche pas à mon poste et à aucun
moment elle ne crache sur m6 et à
l'hypocrite protège-t-elle sa carrière
je pose la question
[Musique]
marco wittmann et tu peux pas rentrer
accord tu te fous de ma gueule donné
leur montrais pas moisir une trop grosse
tête d'un savant rentrée paquet là bas
bien sûr tout est ok alors qu'amiens
voilà voilà bien il m'a dit on dirait
donald kohn
lui c'est cyril hanouna le dark vador du
post
il est obsédé par le rire par les fous
rires
par l'adar cas et par la bonne humeur
mais cette magie tation intempestives ne
traduit-elle pas une angoisse absolue la
peur de disparaître
voire de mourir quand-même et behzad et
nous sommes libres à ce rassemblement
vous aviez un texte
oui mais vous l'aviez oublié non
pourquoi il avait joué j'ai joué je l'
ai vécu j'ai ressenti basse était venu
seul et complètement connecté avec vous
je me sentis à l'étroit pour tous une
révélation
oui
c'est damien caennaise dans le métier on
surnomme l'ambitieux aux dents longues
il a le même âge que maxime gainey a il
parle chiffres comme maxime gainey son
rêve prendre la place de maxime gainey
pas mal mais live comme alain rousset à
la mode c'est la version arabe et non
[Musique]
lui
se rappeler le fennec de tunis comme
s'ils avaient des phonak à tunis
[Musique]
dans la vie à la télé en tout cas c'est
un mec sympa mais dans la vie quand vous
lui faites un sms soit ils vous
répondent les 15 secondes soit il répond
jamais donc j'accuse le fennec de tunis
soin de ne pas savoir lire et voir de ne
pas savoir écrire ça alors voir
affichage est expliquée chéri c'est moi
parce que comme moi j'en suis où je
reçois et d'où je réponds tout de suite
je dis oui c'est ce que je disais là et
bien je vais bien appel de répéter ce
que je viens de dire non c'est moi qui
vais voir les gars là normalement il va
accrocher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle c'est mamie zinzin aussi appelé la
vioque
au piment rouge voilà pourquoi en
interrogeant pendant plusieurs heures
une centaine de voisins les gendarmes
l'apprendront que quatre choses elle a
travaillé dans un zoo elle a fait pékin
express est là étaient comestibles
elle fait l'amour panacotta chaque
week-end avec un certain alain à
certains là qui va mener les gendarmes
un nouveau rebondissement car la vioque
a plus d'un tour dans son sac et sans
rigoler eh les mecs
heureusement c'est le meilleur c'est
celui qui fait le mieux christophe
hondelatte on est d'accord on va
franchement j'ai envie vous êtes gentil
si on s'y met mais moi j'étais 2 gt2
d'amour aussi mais moi j'étais dedans
aussi oui mais vous vous êtes souvent
dedans c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'elle fait en série tous les bons
coups maxime gemmenich je t'accuse
aujourd'hui je devais passer pour le
tombeur de ces dames
alors qu'au final j'ai appris que tu
étais un enquêteur un vrai enquêteurs tu
te renseignes auprès de mes amis pour
savoir avec qui je sors j'aimerais te
dire juste une chose
heureusement les questions à moi on a
privé dans sa gamme ont bien des